tant panier électorale tout ce qu'on
analyse en détail avec mes invités ils
ne sont pas d'accord vous allez le voir
et c'est tant mieux et maintenant 2022
c'est demain à 22h je compte sur vous
amoureux
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bonjour je viens pour
faire ma dose de rappel il ya des rendez
vous à ne pas manquer pour continuer à
vous protéger
penser dès maintenant à votre dose de
rappel
je n'avais jamais pensé qu'on pourrait
vivre autrement mange dans quinze jours
l'union soviétique n'existerait plus de
cercueils aux à elle était
indestructible
et on revit était inimaginable
pas trop comment j'ai
reçu un télégramme qui contenait ce bref
message hakim chef financier revenir on
nous a coupé les financements
laisser tout sur place est rentré on ne
connaissait que le système soviétique
tailleuse et n'obtient nous allait
toujours répété que le capitalisme
c'était le mal une bible c'était le
chaos total qui ne voyait plus la police
elle était occupée à se protéger
elle-même ainsi l'état de protéger vos
yeux ce citoyen c'était terrible le
gamelan les gens étaient devenus
complètement dingue quelqu'un pouvait se
faire tuer pour du chocolat ça me
choquait plus personne ment du rss
l'effondrement samedi à 21h sur public
sénat
[Musique]
je suis revient en teenag anime la
matinale de public sénat c'est tous les
jours de 7h30 à 9h
à peine pour
thomas
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et à tous bienvenue dans
les matins du sénat aujourd'hui je vous
propose de suivre l'audition de bernard
arnault le pdg du groupe lvmh à la tête
cd quotidien les échos le parisien et
radio classique il est auditionné
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur la
concentration des médias à l'initiative
des sénateurs ps elle a pour but
d'évaluer l'impact de cette
concentration sur notre démocratie
hier c'est vincent bolloré actionnaire
majoritaire du groupe bolloré ancien
président du conseil de surveillance de
vivendi et du groupe canal+ qui s'est
retrouvé sur le grill face aux sénateurs
pendant deux heures les sénateurs lui
ont notamment posé des questions sur le
rôle de son groupe dans la diffusion des
idées d'eric zemmour le candidat raid
extrême droite à la présidentielle qui a
été chroniqueur sur ces news pendant
plusieurs années il a aussi vincent
bolloré a tenu à leur rappeler qu'il n'y
a pas d'idéologie politique dans ces
médias l'audition de bernard arnault va
bientôt commencer je vais pouvoir vous
laisser suivre les échanges hier vincent
bolloré a été plusieurs fois questionné
par les sénateurs car il dispose de très
nombreux médias hier david assouline a
même fait la liste de ses très très long
médias et l'audition de bernard arnault
vient juste de commencer alors je vous
propose de suivre les échanges et on se
retrouve tout site après située à la
demande du groupe socialiste écologistes
et républicains et à pour rapporteur
david assouline monsieur bernard arnault
votre parole publique et hérard et
notamment
sur la question des économies que des
médias la commission apprécie donc que
vous ayez pu vous rendre disponible dans
des délais relativement brefs pour
démonter moynier devant ted vous êtes
président directeur général et
actionnaire majoritaire du groupe lvmh
leader mondial de l'industrie du luxe je
ne peux pas citer l'ensemble des marques
que vous détenez et qui incarne la
france à l'international peut-être juste
louis vuitton dior tiffany mais
également le château yquem l'un des vins
les plus prestigieux du monde ce n'est
cependant pas pour cette raison
peut-être malheureusement que nous
allons que nous nous réunissons ce matin
mais nous vous avons demandé de venir ce
jour pour votre engagement dans les
médias il remonte à 1993 avec le rachat
du quotidien économique la tribune puis
l'hebdomadaire investir en 2007 vous
avez cédé la tribune et fait
l'acquisition des échos puis du parisien
et du parisien magazine en 2015 pour
constituer la holding les échos le
parisien présidée par pierre louette que
nous avons entendu le 2 décembre dernier
en plus des titre éponyme le groupe
détient radio classique et le mensuel
connaissance des arts tue pas il aussi
dans la présentation des des titres mais
peut-être que le rapporteur il reviendra
si nous avons souhaité vous entendre
monsieur arnaud c'est parce que vous
incarnez avec et quelques autres les
grands capitaines d'industrie
extérieurs aux médias qu'ils choisissent
d'y investir ce qui constitue une
spécificité française qui n'est pas
nouvelle qui est assez ancienne mais qui
est évidemment mérite d'être de notre
part ait étudié la commission est donc
très impatiente de vous entendre
aujourd'hui je vous propose
l'organisation qui est celle que nous
suivons en fait à toutes nos auditions
je vais vous donner la parole pendant 10
minutes en vous demandant de respecter
les dix minutes tout simplement parce
que après nous avons un certain nombre
de deux questions à vous poser
et en fonctionnant sous forme de
questions réponses le dialogue sera sans
doute plus vif et plus animée et ce qui
vous permettra à travers de bien sûr nos
questions de d'aborder des points que
vous n'aurez pas pu aborder dans l'est
dans les dix minutes
d liminaire je précise que 7 2/10
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du sénat et elle fera
également l'objet d'un compte rendu qui
sera publié enfin je rappelle pour la
forme qu un faux témoignage devant une
autre commission denquête seraient
passibles des peines prévues aux
articles 434 13 14 15 du code pénal je
vous précise également qu'il vous
appartient le cas échéant d'indiquer vos
éventuels liens d'intérêts ou conflits
d'intérêts en relation avec l'objet de
la commission denquête
je vous invite monsieur arnaud a prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je te jure
je vous remercie et je vous donne donc
la parole pendant dix minutes
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et les sénateurs
ne vais pas revenir cette invitation
pour vous parler d'un sujet et je vous
en remercie qui sont les médias et
l'organisation capitalistique
ce sujet est assez marginal
dois dire pour commencer pour le groupe
que le dirigent j'espère donc que mes
propos pour vous
vous éclairer suffisamment car cette
activité n'est pas ma spécialité et je
me contact consacre qu'assez peu de
temps néanmois depuis le début des
années 90 comme le présidentiable de
rappeler lorsque j'ai pris la direction
du groupe lvmh
j'ai bu d'une part approcher la réalité
économique de leur fonctionnement mais
aussi leurs difficultés lorsque la
conjoncture est délicate ou que leur
position concurrentielle et moi
pertinente j'ai pu tirer de ces
constatations quelques idées quant au
rôle de l'actionnaire
que je suis heureux de vous présenter
brièvement avec mon oeil plus
d'entrepreneurs avant de répondre à vos
questions d'abord quels sont les
contours du groupe de presse propriété
de lvmh
vous l'avez rappelé c'est
essentiellement quatre titres de presse
écrite les échos le parisien investir
sens des arts mais aussi des médias ou
division audiovisuel autour de radio
classique essentiellement autour de la
musique classique avec mezzo medici tv
entre autres se sont aussi quelques
grands salons par exemple vivent à tech
qui donne à la tête française un
rayonnement mondial
et ce sont en tout plus de 1600 salariés
dont 644 carte de presse et le chiffre
d'affaires qui tourne autour de 400
millions et malheureusement les pertes
sont
substantielles cet ensemble s'est
constitué lentement et sans plan
concerté les titres concernés ont été le
plus souvent proposé au groupe ares
propriétaires qui souhaitaient s'en
défaire soit parce qu'ils avaient échoué
à trouver des repreneurs aussi passionné
que soit parce qu'ils ne pouvaient plus
faire face aux besoins réguliers de
liquidités
lvmh a ainsi acquis radio classique en
99 alors que pierre faure le président
de la sagem qui l'avait qui en était
propriétaire qui était un ingénieur les
passionnés de musique classique que
cherchait un repreneur connaissance des
arts en cours 2000 lorsque la famille
qui le détenait a souhaité s'en séparer
les échos en 2007 quand le groupe
anglais personne voulait le vendre et
qu'il était alors possible de faire
revenir en france ce puits ce qui est le
premier journal économique français le
parisien 2016 lorsque la famille amaury
a estimé ne plus pouvoir en assumer la
charge
particulièrement lourde pour l'avenir il
récemment phalange dont claude perdriel
un ingénieur comme moi qui a fait de la
presse une des patientes sa vie et qui
est très soucieux de voir son oeuvre de
presse s'appuyer sur des soutiens
solides a souhaité que lvmh reprennent
la part minoritaire
appartenant au groupe renault qui
voulait être la revente
alors pourquoi me direz-vous le groupe
lvmh a acquis tous ces titres les échos
le parisien connaissance des arts radio
classique investir et les autres sont
dans leur domaine des fleurons des
titres dont les noms résonnent dans la
culture collective depuis plus de
cinquante voire 200 ans ce sont des
références
pluriel diverses respectés qu'ils sont
indissociables des domaines de il couvre
la vie économique et sa compréhension ne
seraient pas les mêmes je crois sans les
échos la vie quotidienne locale et
nationale ne serait pas la même sans le
parisien aujourd'hui en france qui en
assurent la couverture la culture des
marchés financiers l'attractivité des
entreprises ne seraient pas aussi
diffusé en france sans investir et la
couverture des événements artistiques ou
musicaux ne serait pas aussi riche sans
connaissance des arts ou radio classique
ils sont dans des domaines différents
irremplaçable c'est pour cela que le
groupe lvmh a accepté de temps à autre
de conforter tel ou tel titre
s'il est une référence incontournable il
nous paraissait en effet nécessaire et
dans l'intérêt général devrait à sa
pérennité
aurait-il survécu s'ils n'avaient pas
reçu l'investissement d'un actionnaire
comme lvmh pour me permettrait d'en
douter compte tenu du nombre de médias
qui ont disparu depuis 20 ans et de
l'ampleur des révolutions technologiques
actuels leur avenir en dépit de leur
qualité était pour le moins à mon avis
un certain
on assiste en effet depuis une dizaine
d'années à un bouleversement mondial est
majeur dans le domaine des médias de
plus en plus de personnes en particulier
les jeunes je vois que mes enfants
remplace la lecture des journaux des
magazines ou la télévision par le regard
quotidien sur les écrans sociaux
planétaire à travers leur smartphone ou
encore des écrans de netflix et consorts
de plus la publicité dépensé dans les
médias traditionnels et en chute au
profit de ces nouveaux médias à
l'audience croissante et mondial
la pérennité des titres traditionnels
dont nous parlons aujourd'hui est donc
loin d'être assurée à terme
elle le serait encore moins je pense si
ces médias n'avaient pas d'actionnaire
puissant capable de les aider pour faire
face à ce défi structurel absolument
fondamental qu'il n'est pas évidente
surmonter et qui nécessite pour
l'affronter des investissements
considérables
permettra des fleurons français de
briller c'est ce qui anime depuis
toujours élevé match vous connaissez les
maisons du groupe président en recul
l'amabilité et d'en citer quelques-unes
je devais pas allonger la liste il y en
a 70 depuis la création du groupe lvmh
mon équipe a concentré toute son
ascension pour bâtir le premier groupe
de luxe mondial autour de cette maison
artisanale prestigieuse pour l'essentiel
française
nous employons aujourd'hui 175 mille
personnes dans le monde et donc un peu
plus de 40000 en france
le groupe année plus de 100 sites de
production des manufactures artisanale
en france il est le premier contributeur
à l'impôt sur les sociétés dans notre
pays bien que son chiffre d'affaires
soit pour l'essentiel plus de 90%
réalisés hors de france lvmh a également
une place importante dans le mécénat
avec notamment la fondation louis
vuitton
tout cela était possible en s'appuyant
sur les valeurs qui animent notre groupe
et qui sont au nombre de quatre jeux les
sites succinctement pourrait évidemment
développé ces thèmes qui sont
passionnantes d'abord la créativité et
l'innovation
ensuite la recherche permanente de la
plus haute qualité
l'esprit entrepreneurial indispensable
au succès économique et la motivation
personnelle et enfin l'engagement
sociétal sociale environnementale qui
donne un sens à notre action
notre relation média s'inscrit dans
cette démarche
investir dans les talents dans
l'innovation insuffler de la créativité
dans leur héritage patrimonial et un
esprit de responsabilité dans leur
gestion alors même si l'activité média
ne constitue qu'une toute petite partie
la réalité économique du groupe nos
valeurs s'applique t elle et c'est sans
doute pour cela que c'est ce que je
pense qu'à travers les dernières
décennies nous avons été à plusieurs
reprises sollicité les vendeurs les
cadres et les journalistes concernés
voyons sans doute chez lvmh un ensemble
de valeurs qui leur correspond
pour conclure cette introduction par un
mot sur le rôle de lvmh en tant qu
actionnaire du groupe de presse les
échos le parisien je dirais qu'il
consiste essentiellement à accompagner
l'adaptation de cette entité face face à
la concurrence de plus en plus forte des
médias numériques planétaire qui
prennent chaque jour plus d'importance
pour les lecteurs les auditeurs les
annonceurs au détriment des médias plus
traditionnels que sont là prête presse
écrite radio ou la télévision
le rôle fondamental de l'actionnaire
lvmh pour ce faire consiste à aider le
groupe les échos le parisien à investir
puissamment dans les outils d'avenir le
web le mobile les nouveaux formats afin
de ne pas se laisser éclipsé trop vite
par les médias merrick mondiaux qui sont
chaque jour plus puissant et plus suivis
par nos concitoyens
pour y parvenir le plus efficacement
possible au plan opérationnel
lvmh a donné à la direction de son pôle
média dirigée par pierre louette que
vous connaissez une totale autonomie là
même qui caractérisa méthodes de gestion
décentralisée de notre groupe et qui
s'appliquent à chacune de ces maisons
voilà quelques mots
proxy messieurs arnaud pour cette
présentation nous allons revenir à
travers nos questions sur un certain
nombre de points que vous avez
abordé dans votre présentation de jeu
nous allons commencer les questions par
celle du rapporteur david assouline
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur
vous avez exposé
les activités que vous avez dans le
domaine des médias
linverse d'une audition qui a eu lieu
hier
ce n'est pas l'ampleur de ces
acquisitions qui
fait l'objet
de votre thé modèles devant notre
commission denquête c'est à dire une
énorme concentration dans le domaine des
médias car la liste est relativement
brève
les échos le parisien aujourd'hui en
france investir radio classique
d'essence des arts mais aussi
boursier.com
c'est des des prises de contrôles
ciblés
et
avec quand même des ambitions me dit-on
est jolie en ce moment dans d'autres
d'un show sur d'autres médias ont on y
reviendra dans tous les cas ce qui nous
intéresse c'est que vous êtes
là un instant on a dit la
plus grande fortune du monde
votre groupe est puissant il a des
activités de nombreux employés dans le
monde
un succès incroyable et même dans ces
moments de pandémie
il augmente ses bénéfices de façon tout
à fait incroyable
donc
on a du mal à penser que une activité
qui est plutôt vous avez dû capitalisées
et c'est parce qu' elle n'est pas
bénéficiaire du tout
dans le dans le domaine de médias et
alors que ce n'est pas votre métier ça
vous l'assumez vous avez choisi de
d'investir dans des médias comme ça pour
pour faire oeuvre de
l'intérêt public d'intérêt général
bien entendu qu'il doit y avoir un
intérêt dit aussi à vos activités
et c'est ça notre interrogation c'est
comment pourquoi des
grands industriels dans des domaines
tout à fait différent vous c'est le luxe
mais le btp pour l'un il ya l'armement
pour l'autre et c'est à vous intéresser
aux médias
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser un
peu plus cet intérêt
notamment avec ce qui est sûr dans le
débat public sur la place publique et
même avec des faits que je citerai
quand on dit que c'est un moyen d'
influence
que c'est un alors vous pouvez appeler
ça le rayonnement
pour
moins influencé aussi un moyen de
contrôler un peu ce que l'on peut dire
de bien ou de mal sur les activités
commerciales que vous avez
dans la presse que répondez vous à cela
leveaux lvmh
s'intéresse comme je le dis dans ma
petite introduction
au fleuron français
ces groupes de presse en font partie
quand il s'est agi d'investir dans ces
groupes de presse
qui représente certes une activité
déficitaire mais extrêmement faible on
valeur absolue par rapport à l'ensemble
d'euros
il nous est apparu nécessaire et
dans l'intérêt général
de le faire d'autant que
sinon certains ces titres n'aurait
peut-être pas survécu et que
vous parler d' influence
notre gauche n'a aucune relation
économique avec les pouvoirs publics les
marchés publics tous à 90% plus de 90%
notre chiffre d'affaires se fait hors de
france donc on voit mal en quoi
une activité
comme celle là que j'en mangerai plus
tôt en ce qui me concerne
je veux pas être péjoratif d'ailleurs
mais du côté du mécénat peut nous donner
une influence quelconque
en ce qui concerne la meinau affaire qui
n'est en rien lié aux pouvoirs publics
fonctionnaient je sais bien qu'il y a
une opinion générale qui est de dire les
investisseurs
dans la presse sont des hommes de médias
qui veulent intervenir
mais dans quel but en ce qui nous
concerne on vois pas l'objectif
l'objectif pour nous c'est de faire en
sorte que ces entreprises réussissent à
redevenir
rentable
d'ailleurs ce qui est atteint
aujourd'hui cette année pour la première
fois depuis dix ans dans les écoles est
de faire en sorte que ce petit groupe de
presse
prosper voilà
c'est notre objectif il ne va pas plus
loin
vous savez que il ya eu un certain
nombre de reproches dans la façon dont
vous avez interférer dans des activités
de presse le jeu donne
plusieurs exemples
vous vous souvenez qu'à la suite de
cette une de libération vous concernant
vous avez supprimé l'ensemble de la
publicité de lvmh
avec 150000 euros de publicité en moins
pour le quotidien de la part du groupe
en novembre deux ans c'était en
septembre 2012 en novembre 2017 il y
avait une enquête du monde et cetera
toujours concernant les parts des spurs
et
[Musique]
le monde a été privée de publicité aussi
pour une hauteur estimée à 600 mille
euros
vous confirmez
que ça peut être des
vacances qui concerne libération parce
que vous avez vu la une en question est
ce que vous aviez le sur le sénateur
l'affût en question
ça vous avez paru tout à fait normal
d'avoir un titre aussi agressif contre
la première entreprise française pour
une motivation fausse parce que j'ai
jamais eu l'intention de devenir
résident fiscal baisse se situe à
fantasmes encore une fois
ça vous aurez plus d'avoir ça et non
seulement il fallait accepter cette une
était on faisait quasiment jamais de
publicité dans libération et lecteurs de
libération son palais des clients du
groupe donc on a dit voilà on s'est
vengé en faisant plus de féliciter mme
on en faisait déjà quasiment pas donc
tout ça c'est
alors je me suis plaint effectivement
j'ai appelé le directeur de l'époque je
sais plus qui s'était enlisé dans
libération
c'est incroyable de pouvoir traiter
des plus grosses entreprises françaises
et son actionnaire à son dirigeant de
cette façon c'est pas peut-être que vous
trouvez ça bien servir et si je ne suis
pas là pour vous dire si je trouve ça
bien ou pas bien et d'ailleurs je
absolument
le droit plein et entier d'être choqués
d'être pas d'accord avec la façon dont
la presse que traiter ou votre personne
ou nos activités mais le sujet que l'on
traite la
indépendamment des personnes c'est le
sujet des possibilités par la puissance
économique on financière
d'utiliser cela pour interférer sur la
liberté de la presse parce que il a
d'autres moyens si
vous avez est-ce que vous avez d'autres
exor je vais je finis sur le monde je
vous dis ces fonds et sur libération de
toute façon faisait pas toubib cité
alors vous pouvez le problème bien
obligé moi je vais vous répondre et je
répète je répète ce que vous avez
d'autres agents spéciaux nateur est ce
que vous êtes d'autres exemples me
montrer alors ensuite il y a quelque
chose qui a fait un peu plus l'actualité
c'est ces derniers jours d'ailleurs
mais je pense que ça vous reconnaîtrez
il y a eu
d'embauchés on va dire en tous les cas
de missionné
par votre groupe
monsieur bernard quartz square si ni
enquêté sur la vie privée et sur la vie
tout court de monsieur rufin qui était
en train de faire un film qui va ça sauf
merci patron plus tard je répète je ne
juge pas telle ou telle chose je suis
factuelle que je vous pose la question
la justice a
acté le fait qu'il y avait eu cela et a
proposé que moyennant le versement de 10
millions que vous avez accepté la sphère
seraient closes
me confirmer cela pourquoi comment
qu'elle suit vous avez donné vous même
dans votre entreprise à
cette affaire
alors dans cette affaire d'abord
il faut savoir que c'est la justice qui
a proposé aux services juridiques
d'élever masse cette formule de cgg
saisi été plus fade 2
d'accord
conventionnelle mention général
d'intérêt public on n'avait pas demandé
c'est le juge qui l'a proposée aux quais
et dans ce document que vous pouvez le
consulter nous avons reconnu aucune
culpabilité
donc je réfute toute culpabilité ce qui
a été approuvé par la justice française
dans ce dossier si on essayait
d'insinuer que des coupables en quoi que
ce soit dans cette affaire c'est le
sénateur je vous invite à lire la
décision de justice
je répète je ne suis pas je suis pas
d'eau dans un dialogue personnel avec
vous je
10 ce qui est et je vous demande de
réagir justement je vous donne la
possibilité de donner des explications
et donc je vous avais accepté de donner
10 millions pour quelque chose où il n'y
a aucun sujet pour vous c'était comme ça
on l'a donc on a le le juge nous a
proposé cette transaction afin d'éviter
que nous soyons
pris dans cette affaire à laquelle on
n'avait rien à voir
notamment vous fait une responsabilité
voilà
quant à monsieur refait
surface tout le monde connaît c'est
quelqu'un de très brillant qui est
d'extrême gauche et pour lequel le
groupe l ema depuis toujours
est un épouvantail
alors pourquoi ce nom un épouvantail
parce que nous sommes français parce
qu'on en danse en france parce qu'on
crée des ateliers en france et que c'est
un contre-exemple tellement flagrant
pour sa stratégie de communication qu'il
est obligé d'essayer de trouver des poux
dans la tête partout et si on a essayé
d'éviter que monsieur rifai lors d'une
assemblée générale où il avait prévu de
venir pour enfarinée tout le monde ne
puisse entrer dans la salle
franchement je vois pas le problème
non mais
je ne prenais pas sur l'allemagne
[Musique]
sur la même longueur d'onde de réflexion
je répète ce qui nous intéresse ici
c'est de voir les possibles
interférences
delà de puissance économique sur la
liberté d'expression la liberté de la
presse l'effet que nous je parle les
invente pas comme moi qui étais les
chercher ils sont là et donc ce que je
sais cette mesure rufin dans cette
affaire lui n'accepte pas le jugement
c'est-à-dire qui le jeu et que vous vous
l'acceptez vous donner des millions
uniquement parce que vous considérez que
c'est une vue c'est à dire que
maintenant si quelqu'un
vous attaque alors que les faits sont
infondées pour pas que d'affaires c'est
ça pour pas qu'on en parle et bien vous
donner des millions je ne pense pas que
c'est complètement comme ça mais la
presse est documenté les shows chacun se
fait une opinion mais j'aime moi j'ai eu
votre réponse et ça et c'est
on peut continuer cette audition sur des
questions qui touchent un peu plus à
vous me confirmer que vous êtes encore
une participation dans l'opinion
journal opinion le journal l'opinion
ah oui on a un investissement tout à
fait minoritaire dans l'opinion mais
c'est moi j'ai 24 lui pour sow
ensuite il ya la régie publicitaire
comment la régie publicitaire du groupe
le parisien les échos agi vis-à-vis des
marques du groupe lvmh
comme la régie publicitaire
de tous organismes de presse on est dans
des relations
les marques elles essayent de les
convaincre
d'acheter des publicités de vente en
leur rendant leur mauvais d'ailleurs si
je sais pas si vous avez posé la
question à pierre louette mais il se
plaint régulièrement il fait que nos
marines investissent pas assez et plus
dans d'autres médias donc problème là
c'est plutôt le fait que le groupe est
sous investisseurs par rapport aux
autres dans les magazines du groupe et
ça vous pouvez le vérifier ce que vous
avez les sucres
pouvez vous me préciser les raisons qui
vous ont poussé à dénoncer le pacte
d'actionnaires qui vous dit arnaud
lagardère en septembre dernier autre
autre acteur discret mais qui est
investi nos la presse
arnaud lagardère
celui de soutenir gelé soutenu est on
arrivé à un moment où
il avait choisi un autre partenaire de
tous pour son organisation
capitalistique donc
je vois qu'on a été associé
dans une société en commandite et qui a
été ensuite transformés dans une société
normale donc à partir devant et avec
huit commandés et plus tellement
d'intérêt
d'avoir l'accord particulier les cuit
puisqu'il devenait président directeur
général d'une société anonyme si je me
rappelle bien la structure qui a été
fait a
alors cessé sur le même sujet par qui
des traîtres et billet à la
ycompris à l'audition que nous avons eu
hier et que nous aurons plus tard avec
monsieur lagardère
pour qu'on comprenne bien et y compris
ce qui va se passer pour nous viendrons
vous étiez vous
partisan de
prendre
les parts chez lagardère que finalement
en bolloré à monsieur bolloré a obtenu
pour vous nous raconter un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé à votre avis en tous les
cas au moins votre avis ce
qui a fait
quand notre choix était fait par
monsieur lagardère
pensez-vous inévitable loupé à qui aura
lieu le mois prochain probablement
lagardère sur
deux
du groupe bolloré sur l'europe lagardère
europe 1 paris match
journal du dimanche et les maisons
d'édition
écoutez
quand arnaud lagardère m'a appelé deux
ans c'est parce qu'ils étaient
confrontés un activiste si je me
rappelle bien qui était entré dans son
capital on m'a donc demandé si j'étais
prêt ça c'est pas lvmh assemat société
familiale
participer dans sa société
personnelle en commandite
de celle de pommes tromper
enfin en était donc là pour le soutenir
et face à cet actionnaire
activiste en sus les choses ont évolué
et finalement le quoique
arnaud lagardère a passé un accord
qui est maintenant tout à fait public
avec le groupe de vincent bolloré dont
notre présence dans cette société là ils
étaient moins évidentes et nous sommes
aujourd'hui actionnaire petit
actionnaire 3 10 % de la société
anonyme qui en résulte voilà voilà à peu
près
il ya il ya une n'a congo rites et
souvent dans nos réflexions parce que
mon
sur la question des aides à la presse
pensez vous que ces aides à la presse ou
distribués de façon juste et équitable
alors que votre groupe qui a quand même
une certaine sécurité
et le de loin encore le principal
bénéficiaire avec
ils ont déjà plus de deux fois plus que
le deuxième qui en bénéficient qui est
le figaro et le monde
[Musique]
le principe
vous avez peut-être
réfléchi qui serait de faire de la
discrimination entre tel ou tel titre
parce que son actionnaire est plus ou
moins solide ça je vois pas très bien
comment quelques se justifier ou on fait
des aides à la presse et à ce moment là
il faut que ça se fasse de manière un
peu veut cuménique où on en fait pas du
tout parce qu'il peut aussi se défendre
mais
après comment vous allez choisir entre
tel actionnaire ce qui est assez solide
et l'autre il est moins solide donc on
va donner moins on est partis dont
quelque chose
j'ai juste le principe qu'on va mois ce
qui nous le plus et plus à se tourner ou
le moins connaître qu'on peut imaginer
ça
bah moi je suis partisan de garder un
système à peu près également réparties
ou de le supprimer mon pote ben
moi je voudrais revenir sur les
conditions et économique vous avez bien
décrit dans votre propos liminaire
le contexte économique des médias en
disant que c'est un secteur économique à
la rentabilité faible ce qu'on veut bien
entendre parce que ça corrobore un
certain nombre de témoignages qu'on a eu
jusqu'à présent de
deux personnes qui sont venues dans
cette commission denquête tous sauf un
qui hier nous a dit au contraire
chiffres à l'appui que la rentabilité
opérationnelle était forte dans le
secteur des médias il a
un sens bolloré pour
elle le nommer qui nous a donné des
chiffres sur la marge d'ebitda en
moyenne en disant qu'il y avait deux
secteurs particulièrement rentable le
luxe et les médias l'automobile les
cosmétiques intervenants loin derrière
les chiffres sont assez étonnants et ne
correspond pas à l'analyse que que vous
avez un jeu ne pas vous demander de
commenter des chiffres qui ne sont qui
ne sont pas les vôtres mais est ce qui
est une possibilité de rendre l'activité
média financièrement rentable
alors je pense qu'il ya moyen de la
rendre rentable d'ailleurs je voulais
dit tout à l'heure les échos sont
actuellement l équilibre donc on essaye
de faire en sorte que le reste revient
aussi à l'équipe
quant au fait que ce soit le deuxième
secteur le plus rentable après le luxe
je pense que vincent bolloré a raison
mais il fait référence à ces grosses
sociétés mondiales qui sont des sociétés
de médias si vous prenez facebook si
vous prenez
microsoft maintenant qui est en train de
se développer là dedans face et des
sociétés extrêmement rentable donc est
d'ailleurs une des questions mon année
laquelle il serait intéressant de
réfléchir c'est pourquoi ces sociétés là
ont été créés aux etats-unis et pas en
europe je pense que c'est ça le problème
plutôt pas j'aime pas interférer sur les
débats du sénat mais plutôt de se
concentrer sur les entreprises
françaises qui existent actuellement qui
sont difficiles au niveau de leurs
résultats qui sont aidés par des gouttes
financier capitaliste
alors on peut critiquer on peut dire oui
van maele faut pas leur prêter des
arrière-pensées ce qui me concerne en a
pas bon mais le problème de fond c'est
quand même que l'europe perd son
leadership depuis des années depuis le
début des années 2000 pourquoi facebook
a été créé aux états unis n'avaient pas
été créés en europe c'est ça le vrai
problème auquel il faudra réfléchir
c'est peut-être là dessus que enfin je
n'ai pas de conseils à lui donner une
réunion temps kate sénatoriale pourrait
être très intéressante je serai prêt à
venir il participait à nous aussi volé
pourquoi on a raté ça qu'est ce qu'on
n'a pas fait dans notre pays ou en
europe en général pour que des
entreprises comme ça se crée ici y pas
de raison que ça secret aux états unis
alors maintenant un peu plus de start-up
un peu plus ça commence à s'accélérer et
on est partis gratton après sa vrai
sujet mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
tellement celui le sujet de notre
commission denquête quoique notre
problématique est aussi de faire
ancêtres et des vrais leaders mondiaux
dans le domaine des médias et
qu'ils soient d'origine française ou
d'origine européenne et on voit bien
qu'il ya d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
groupements qui sont en train d'opérer
ces derniers mois et ces derniers mois
je pense à à tf1 et m6 est par exemple
et l'argument des responsables de 2 td
des responsables de tf1 est clairement
celui que vous énoncez c'est à dire
faire émerger un leader je pense qu'ils
ont raison sans doute ça c'est mon avis
je ne sais pas et je dessine je pense
qu'ils ont raison de ce point de vue je
voulais vous interrogez parce que
évidemment compte tenu de la puissance
de votre groupe on vous avait précisé la
stratégie mais qui est une stratégie
assez prudente sur la question des
médias on peut en comprendre les raisons
on vous prête aussi beaucoup d'intention
à tort ou à raison donc c'est le moment
peut-être de clarifier les choses on
vous aide notamment on a cité le nom de
votre groupe sur l'acquisition de m6 et
puis également sur le site du figaro est
ce que c'est des interrogations des
strade des options que vous avez étudié
auquel vous avez finalement renoncé
alors écouter sur
m6 on n'a pas étudié le dossier on nous
l'a demandé a sollicité parce que compte
tenu de la taille du gros
quand un gros dossier se présente
on nous contacte mais on n'a pas étudié
quant au figaro j'ai vu encore hier que
le monde disait qu'on avait fait une
offre et ça c'est quand même très
étonnant ça vous montre quand même les
limites de la presse
c'est faux
je leur ai dit à plusieurs reprises
je le confirme aujourd'hui sous serment
est néanmoins ils écrivent ils
continuent à les créer c'est quand même
étonnant nous n'avons jamais fait
d'offre serait plus grand
et c'est repris systématiquement dans
les articles comme celui vous avez vu
hier
non mais ça ça montre quand même les
limites des voyages ma capacité
d'influencé limitée ce qui montre aussi
qu'il ya peut-être des coups à prendre
quand on s'engage trop dans les médias
ce qui est des bouées de toute façon si
moi j'ai l'habitude aussi de me faire
attaquer
la réussite d'un groupe économique en
france
c'est pas forcément quelque chose qui
est bien vu je le regrette
c'est dommage
certains autres pays
font de ces groupes des héros bon en
france pour s est plutôt cachée et
on se fait critiquer quand ça marche
bien on se fait encore plus critique et
même si on emploie beaucoup de monde
même si le groupe en question embauchent
plus de dix mille personnes par an en
france même si on est le premier
contributeur aux impôts français est
critiqué j'ai vu des crimes on a fait la
fondation nous héritons vous êtes
peut-être pas suivi les critiques qu'on
a eu vent pour ça même le dire on
faisait ça pour éviter l'impôt pour le
faire on a dépensé près de 800 millions
on fait des expositions il y en a une en
ce moment qu'il serait très bien donc ça
c'est pas quelque chose qui est rentable
maintenant est-ce quelque chose qui
coûte des tensions pour faire venir une
collection pareil
musée terrus
ça se fait pas tout seul
des contreparties mais je pense que pour
la france c'est formidable c'est la
première fois qu'une élection comme ça
est réuni à paris mais néanmoins on est
critiqués quand j'ai fait un don pour
reconstruire
notre dame je pensais je me dis quand là
tout le monde va trouver ça bien ben non
non vous vous est critique et maintenant
ils auraient mieux fait de donner ça aux
impôts et que l'état le pays comme ils
font maintenant mais je vous dis juste
qu'il ya un état et peut-être que ça
explique aussi pourquoi les grands
entrepreneurs potentiels
les jeunes les chercheurs cetera
devant cet environnement ont du mal à
aboutir en france
si je peux me permettre dans
l'environnement politique quand je vois
ce à quoi les responsables politiques
sont soumis en ce moment ça décourage
pas dans l'évocation
des bons sentiments
autour de la table des gens qui ont
encore la vocation ils vont
ce que déjà ça tant d'amis dans cette et
je sais c'est difficile les maires les
maires qui sont attaqués son arrêt
ça décourage un peu je suis donné la
parole
mes collègues maintenant pour une
première c'est pour l'heure question
j'aurais manganèse merci président
bonjour monsieur arnaud si j'en juge par
le nombre de photographes que keenu qui
vous attend dès ce matin et si j'osais
je dirais que c'est un luxe de vous
recevoir ici au sénat
vous avez fait référence tout à l'heure
à votre vision d'entrepreneurs et à
titre personnel c'est bien celle là que
je viens chercher ce matin et dont je
crois nous avons bien besoin au sein de
la commission denquête
votre réussite et celle du groupe est
totalement exceptionnel
et les françaises vous l'avez dit fait
croyez bien qu'un bon nombre
de personnes en france en ont conscience
elle ne tient pas au miracle elle tient
à la fois au travail acharné à
l'intelligence et à la détermination
vous avez donné d'ailleurs les quatre
axes principaux de façon globale de
votre stratégie
et je crois qu'en cette période
électorale
je pense qu'elle serait ces quatre axes
serait bon à rappeler à tous les
candidats et candidates aux élections
présidentielles la créativité
la haute qualité
l'esprit d'entreprise
l'engagement et vous avez même rajouté
après ce à quoi nous sommes
excessivement attaché ici au sénat la
gestion décentralisée
et dieu sait si notre pays a du mal avec
ça alors ma question elle est
relativement simple
la concentration qui nous tient dans
cette commission enquête c'est un sujet
économique
le pluralisme lui c'est un sujet de
démocratie alors comment à votre avis
concilier la nécessaire recomposition du
marché des médias
avec la non moins nécessaire
préservation de ce pluralisme qui fait
vivre la démocratie
on va dire que on est dans un pays où
les médias sont libres
aujourd'hui si on veut faire sortir le
journaliste veut faire sortir en
articles négatifs
sur le président de la république sur
run ministre sur eux
un responsable politique un article
négatif sur un dirigeant d'entreprise
il peut le faire évidemment il faut que
ce soit nanti fondé ou avec des
arguments il faut le faire on est quand
même dans un pays où la liberté de la
presse la liberté de la communication
est assurée
je pense que
il faut pas exagérer l'impact que
pourraient avoir
certaines opérations de rapprochement
parler de tf1 de m6
vous parlez de d'autres
intervenants
je ne vois pas
pourquoi
de telles opérations
pourraient le changer
la liberté qui est fondamental de la
communication en france et l'esprit
français
il y aurait de telles protestations le
tél
ça ne marcherait pas et donc l inverse
si on crée beaucoup de réglementation
complémentaires
et la france est aussi un pays
peut-être dans les affaires en général
dans les entreprises les réglementations
augmente augmente tous les ans et
deviennent on doit être les champions
des réglementations de tous ordres
ça ça n'est pas favorable
à la prise d'initiative au lancement
d'entreprise donc je serai très prudent
moi je ne peux pas vous dire ce qu'il
faut faire mais je serai ce prudent de
rajouter encore une couche de
réglementation complémentaires
parce que ça va ça va freiner les
initiatives
alors
je ne peux pas aller beaucoup plus loin
parce que je peux vous dire quoi faire
c'est pas c'est pas mon métier encore
une fois les médias c'est pas ma
spécialité
est ce que ce que pense qu'il faudra
essayer de se mettre en situation de
favoriser s'il doit y avoir des nouveaux
médias internet vita de favoriser leur
apparition leur création leur
développement à partir de france
beaucoup d'ordres s'est tu sais quand
même ce qu'ils mangent parce que
aujourd'hui moi je vois mes enfants mais
il espère jean
viard n'a pas été et regardent leurs
écrans donc c'est le pelage les des gens
qui regardent date et a arrêté
d'augmenter vous la publicité illicite
et aujourd'hui moi je vois dans d'autres
où on a bougé complètement des médias
traditionnels aux médias internet et les
sommes maintenant on fait plus de la
moitié des investissements
et ça ça a changé en dix ans sur les
médias internet au détriment
des magazines certains d'ailleurs sont
au bord de la catastrophe économique
donc
avant de rajouter nouvelle
réglementation extrêmement
contraignantes quand même un peu
attention voilà michel logique merci
monsieur le président monsieur bonjour
c'est vrai que dans une ambiance assez
morose de la france actuellement
aggravée par la pandémie ça fait plaisir
de recevoir ici les personnes qui font
rayonner la france de manière plus que
positive dans le monde entier
justement
cette commission des requêtes nous
permet de recevoir beaucoup de grands
noms de l'industrie française
donc vincent bolloré et lagardère xavier
niel patrick drahi vous même je
trouverais ça vous l'avez un petit peu
pleuré mais j'aimerais connaître
vraiment qu'est ce qui attire selon vous
les plus grands industriels
dans les médias ça c'est ma première
question baptisé mes questions
ça serait de vous avez parlé de
changement d'usagé on ne l'est plus
aujourd'hui et même façon vous avez fait
référence à vos enfants n'écoutent plus
la radio de la même façon ne regardent
plus la télévision de la même de la même
façon
donc est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez de nouvelles ambitions
le président la faune vous a
interrogé sur m6 et sur le figaro mais
peut-être qu'il ya d'autres choses parce
que vous êtes limité à cette réponse là
mais elle souhaite d'autres ambitions
vers d'autres médias ça c'est ma
deuxième question est la troisième
puisqu'elle avait évoqué plusieurs fois
ce sont les grandes plateformes vous
avez dit planétaire un pagne n'ai pas
dit un tabac seul planétaire juste de
bons est-ce que vous ne serez pas
intéressé pour créer une plateforme
planétaire
bon alors qu'est ce qui attire les
investisseurs dans les médias
je pense que souvent
c'est des propositions en tout cas en ce
qui nous concerne ce qui leur arrive
on nous sollicite
le débat pourquoi vous voulez pas
aidé dans telle ou telle situation c'est
ce qui s'est passé avec vous l'avez
rappelé le président avec arnaud
lagardère c'est ce qui s'est passé
récemment quand mon ami claude perdriel
devait trouver quelqu'un qui achetaient
la participation minoritaire c'est
encore lui qui dirige complètement le
challenge super six amis dans les terres
détenues par renault et il préférait
probablement que ce soit avec et à
l'excellente relation
estime réciproque donc c'est c'est chez
nous en tout cas c'est un long processus
on sait pas c'est un long processus et
ça reste extrêmement petit par rapport à
l'ensemble du goût donc c'est pas
quelque chose
comme nos recherches entreprises dans
développement externe
mondiale d'en acheter et certainement
l'année dernière une entreprise
américaine
[Musique]
des petits fanni qui est la première
marque américaine une des premières
marques mondiales des deux voiliers ont
ça c'est un très bon investissement et
donc on va donc personnellement je pense
à beaucoup de temps à ces affaires-là et
et le groupe
beaucoup moins
autre opportunité dans les médias alors
lesquels vous pourrez faire dans
l'avenir ça dépend de celle qu'on va
nous proposer
pour l'instant
les moteurs des mânes excusez moi mais
oui c'est le masque un sas et le masque
ses problèmes du moins c'est ce qu'on
m'a donné un masque spécial l'impression
qu'il est moins et le son se transmet
moins
donc
pour
les la suite d'une manière générale si
on lui en donne pas nos projets alors je
sais bien qu'on ait nous a semblé tout à
fait spécial aujourd'hui mais de même
que deux ans mais mes actionnaires je
donne pas le projet
voilà mais tout cas les deux que vous
avez évoquées ne figure pas dans la
liste des projets alors démarrer
démarrer une
une société
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'on
participe depuis longtemps dans toute
une série de start up je ne sais pas si
vous le savez vous savez peut-être pas
mais par exemple être flix en 2000
j'étais un des actionnaires de départ le
fixe on avait pratiquement dans mon
groupe familial près de 20% de cette
société et d'ailleurs c'est très amusant
parce que l époque de business model
n'avait rien à voir ils envoyaient par
la poste des petits dvd que vous louiez
pendant un mois et que vous leur envoyez
est le fondateur m'avait expliqué mais
maintenant avec le développement de
l'internet et tout ça on va faire de la
vidéo on demande de la voix ça va être
le nouveau système est fait et ça a
marché
après
ouais je peux pas je ne peux pas faire
ça je peux participer
et des finances est pas mon groupe
familial des créateurs
qui doivent avoir la flamme et l'idée
parce que ce qui compte dans une aile en
semant de startups comme ça à la fois
l'idée et après c'est la mise en oeuvre
c'est d'ailleurs quand vous regardez
facebook c'est d'ailleurs assez étonnant
de voir que à l'époque où ils ont du
coeur balance et facebook
pas mal d'autres sociétés avec la même
idée et se sont lancés en même temps est
la seule qui ait marché
vraiment c'est facebook parce que
l'exécution était parfaite et c'est donc
dans les entreprises c'est la même chose
dans des entreprises payées ya l'idée il
ya la créativité et l e le créateur
génial
mais après il faut exécuter et si
l'exécution est pas là
ça beaucoup moins de choses de
fonctionner mais moi ça m'intéresse
beaucoup regarde d'ailleurs des stats on
est actionnaire actuellement de la
première la plus grosse l'icône
française il s'appelle black up market
et qu'il en a qui vont des sur le 10
euros nets et des téléphones
reconditionnés qui en plus à côté
écologique
non mais ça c'est passionnant c'est vrai
mais ça m'intéresse énormément
mais je vous garantis pas de faire un
facebook français
monique de marco
c'est merci pour ces précisions monsieur
arnaud et pour votre investissement avec
black market c'est à dire une entreprise
qui ont peu apprécié par sa volonté
justement travaillé sur le recyclage
mais là ce sont tannés de questions je
souhaitais rebondir sur deux questions
qu'a posées david assouline
celles concernant la transaction de
votre groupe lvmh sur moyennant la
condamnation pour espionnage sur le jean
el fakir un constat aucun des journaux
dont vous êtes propriétaires comme les
échos le parisien non relayé cette
information
peut-on considérer ceci comme une forme
d'autocensure ou un non événement c'est
ma première question
ma deuxième question votre groupe les
échos le parisien qui est aussi
propriété de lvmh a capté en 2010 9 24%
des aides directes à la presse vous
critiquez souvent l'intervention de
l'état le service public et les emplois
publics néanmoins votre groupe se taille
la part du lion pourrait-on dire dans
les aides publiques sur sur les serbes
sur la presse n'y voyez pas une
contradiction
telle est ma question
concernant
les aides je crois que j'ai répondu si
vous voulez les aides
elles sont réparties en fonction de
chaque titre d'une certaine méthode
on peut critiquer ça on sait pas à moi
de régler le problème et je ne suis pas
quant aux
offenses que les journaux du groupe
n'ont pas cité
l'accord transactionnel qui a été c'est
ça la question moi j'en sais rien
franchement je ne sais pas
ce que c'est quand même un non événement
je ne sais pas il faudrait poser la
question j'en ai dit c'est assez a dû
être pris dans d'autres journaux enfin
je sais pas mais en tout cas bon je
suppose qu'il fait ça
je n'ai pas je n'ai jamais actuellement
pas de commentaires à faire là-dessus
[Musique]
et ben line renaud garabédian merci
monsieur le président monsieur arnaud je
vous êtes à la tête du plus grand groupe
industriel de luxe dans le monde que
vous avez construit patiemment avec
comme tout capitaine d'industrie une
vision d'en arriver à terme à ce que
vous souhaitiez vous avez bâti un empire
de la culture française qui rayonne dans
le monde je vous avoue que moi j'en suis
très fier
malheureusement en france la réussite
n'est pas toujours où je dirais même
rarement vu d'un bon oeil encore moins
admirer ou cité comme exemple de
commissions aujourd'hui elles portent
sur les liens entre la concentration des
médias et la démocratie moi j'ai une
question simple à vous poser est ce que
vous pensez que vous ne seriez pas
attaqué de la même manière si vous
n'aviez pas des activités dans les
médias ou bien pensez vous qu'il s'agit
tout simplement d'un argument
supplémentaire merci de votre réponse
non je pense que je suis critiqué
malheureusement
en contrepartie de la réussite du groupe
et les médias au niveau de la réussite
économique
encore une fois il y contribue pour une
somme négative donc
la critique malheureusement et elle
n'est pas général non plus faut pas
exagérer mais dans toute une série
d'interventions de responsables
politiques publiques en citer un tout à
l'heure
c'est pour presque
mauvais de voir la réussite d'une
entreprise française c'est
qu'aujourd'hui élevée masse est la
première entreprise européenne
l échelle mondiale d'ailleurs c'est pas
non plus énorme on est plus petit que
les géants dont on parle les facebook et
et compagnie mais
c'est une réussite économique
qui est en france qui s'appuie sur
la création d'emplois qui s'appuie sur
le développement
de l'artisanat
on a un travail pour la formation des
artisans français on a un jeune institut
des métiers d'excellence qui forment des
milliers d'artisans pour essayer de
conserver ses métiers en france
tout ça c'est extrêmement positif et
c'est reconnu comme tel par une bonne
partie de l'opinion des jets céderait
que les critiques
sont dérangés par les succès français
d'une certaine façon alors est ce que le
fait d'avoir des média augmente ou pas
les critiques mon avis c'est un peu
indifférent je pense soyez je pense
julien par le temps qui est derrière son
écran je viens d'avoir
le temps sénateur de paris merci
monsieur allard nous de votre présence
et citations pour la fondation et les
très belles expositions qu'elle elle
organise c'était un plus énorme la
capitale de la france alors en octobre
dernier la société des journalistes des
échos a demandé au directeur de la
rédaction à ce que la mention
propriétaire des échos soit
systématiquement à poser quand son site
et votre groupe lvmh et un ding ou ses
filiales ces règles qui proviennent
d'une charte éthique adopté il ya une
dizaine d'années manque parfois de
visibilité que pensez vous de ce type de
chats que fait votre groupe pour les
rendre plus lisibles trouvez vous normal
qu'on indique à chaque fois vos
fonctions lorsque vous êtes cité dans un
article est de même pour le parisien que
vous possédez depuis 2015 qui ne sait
pas lui doté de petits de telles charges
est ce que vous pensez qu'il serait plus
simple plus lisible et bien à chaque
fois que vous êtes mentionné pour éviter
les débats que qui ont été cités dans le
temps dans cette commission que tout
simplement on rappelle que vous êtes un
propriétaire de tel ou tel journal au
moment où vous êtes cité s'est fait
parfois or certains propriétaires dans
certains journaux et mais pas
systématiquement que pensez vous de ce
sujet merci beaucoup
pour tout monsieur le sénateur que c'est
appliqué même d'eau par ailleurs
et que même aujourd'hui dans le parisien
quand on parle
du groupe lvmh vous et moi ou des
projets il toujours une mention
propriétaire et variées je n'ai pas
d'exemple en tête tout ça n'est pas été
fait voyez donc je suis d'accord avec ça
jusqu'où ça normal et je pense que c'est
fait
sylvie robert
oui merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur arnaud alors je vais continuer
donc sur ces phénomènes de concentration
qui ne sont pas nouveaux c'est pas
depuis hier depuis avant-hier mais
effectivement si cette commission
denquête s'est mise en place et que
sont des phénomènes qui prennent de
l'ampleur et qui peuvent un moment
interrogé sur la question mes collègues
lundi du pluralisme ou de la démocratie
on a vu dans déjà beaucoup d'auditions
que nous avons effectué des motivations
qui sont des motivations d'ordre
économique très clairement d'autres des
motivations d'ordre peut-être
idéologiques voire politique où nous
vous avez dix
mois ce qui était important par rapport
aux valeurs du groupe c'est de pouvoir
répondre aux propositions que l'on m'a
fait pour sauver jeudi sauvé je ne sais
pas s'il faut employer ce terme les
fleurons de delà de notre culture on va
dire française et parallèlement et c'est
un sujet très important dans ce contexte
l'évolution des usages des grandes
plateformes font qu'à un moment on
s'interroge sur ce qui va se passer
demain et je voudrais du coup vous poser
de questions très simples est-ce que et
vous l'avez dit dans nos traditions je
ne demande pas un avis
tout de suite sur la question de la
fusion
tf1 m6 mais vous avez dit je pense
qu'ils ont raison
ça m'amène à vous poser une question et
vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui il faut
encore plus concentré
donc pour pouvoir parce que c'est quand
même ça être en capacité de lutter ou en
tout cas par rapport à cette grande
plateforme numérique est ce qu'on en a
encore les capacités
ou parce que c'est une des motivations
un kiki qui est énoncé c'est à dire que
face à face à ce contexte là il faut
devenir de plus en plus gros et du coup
est ce que vous vous ne pensez que c'est
ça a du sens et du coup ma deuxième
question est ce qu'au contraire parce
que ces phénomènes interroge questionne
sur ces questions de pluralisme il ne
faudrait pas peut-être inventé un autre
modèle qui permettrait justement parce
qu'on a toujours été attaché la question
la diversité dans notre pays on le voit
dans d'autres dans d'autres domaines
d'ailleurs je pense à la musique par
exemple
est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas au
contraire et là du coup en tant que
législateur c'est important pour nous de
vous entendre inventer un autre modèle
qui permettrait non pas de concentrer
mais de travailler sur des seuils d
travaille sur des garanties qui existe
déjà un mais d'aller au delà pour
pouvoir ou alors des participations
qu'ils soient un peu différente en fait
le modèle économique de la presse
aujourd'hui qui permettrait de donner
une valeur ajoutée à ce contexte qui
vous l'avez dit n'est pas ni français ni
européen mais américains voire même et
sur lequel on a quand même du mal
aujourd'hui à lutter merci
écoutez moi je pense
effectivement
le problème de la télévision c'est
l'apparition d'une concurrence
internationale
disait planétaire
de toutes ses
créations relativement récente et
youtube netflix cette erreur qui exerce
une concurrence
très forte par rapport à
la télévision classique
qu'elle est l'inconvénient d'une de
concentration
et quel est son avantage plainte
l'inconvénient que vous envisagez
j'imagine c'est au niveau de la
communication
de tout ce qui concerne
les journaux télévisés tayrac qui
seraient regroupées
savoir quand même que veut aujourd'hui
je suis pas là pour défendre tf1
absolument pas parler aux gens de tf1
mais c'est tf1 sur ce plan là même si le
niveau
d'ailleurs le téléspectateur augmente
régulièrement
ils sont comme entête très très
nettement et je crois que m6 sur la
partie communication ils sont pas
extérieurement toi donc
l'union faisant la force en matière
économique pour lutter contre
ces nouvelles plateformes
je pense qu'ils sont mieux de réunir à
l'earl heures d'efforts plutôt que
d'avoir de cette quantité c'est pareil
et
la télévision aujourd'hui
ce qui intéresse le plus me semble-t-il
qu'on aime c'est le sport et les films
et pour faire ça il faut des moyens de
plus en plus gros
justement parce que amazon
est ce qu'on veut laisser amazon diffusé
de manière exclusive les matchs de foot
français c'est peut-être est-ce que la
formule 1 qui en reprend de l'intérêt
doit être diffusé en dehors d'eux
en france en dehors des chaînes
françaises donc plus
un groupe télévision a les moyens
d'investir plus il a les moyens de faire
face à cette concurrence là moi je
raisonne comme ça sans connaître
vraiment le sujet je me suis jamais
intéressé est tellement la télévision
vous ai dit tout à l'heure m6 se levait
pas regardé le dossier bon mais
c'est un réflexe jeunes entrepreneurs
et les craintes que vous avez
mais quand même de moins en moins de
jeunes moi je vois mes enfants est ici
aujourd'hui
il regarde pas le journal télévisé
et donc d'ici 25 ans
qui va regarder j'en ai c'est une visée
ne sais pas
donc
tout ça
ça il faut pas non plus
se laisser trop marquée par un syndrome
de
problèmes qui a trait à la vous avez
raison à la démocratie mais la
démocratie en france quand même
lalonde est un pays de grande liberté
d'expression nous semble-t-il
[Musique]
bernard keller
merci monsieur
arnaud pour vos explications donc vous
comprenez que nous adhérons sur le
problème de la concentration des médias
avec le risque qu'ils encourent pour la
pluralité de l'information
et la deuxième chose c'est pour la
défense pro 7 et permettre la poursuite
de la liberté de création en france et
du rayonnement de la culture française
alors vous vous nous dites intervenir un
peu par mécénat ont dit que ça peut
c'est un domaine des médias qui peut
être profitable
mais pour gagner comme ça des parts de
marché enfin pour conquérir le monde
est-ce que on peut
continuer voilà à défendre et à faire
vivre une culture française ou bien au
contraire pour répondre aux demandes
d'une clientèle
s'internationaliser et finalement
diluer notre culture dans une culture
mondialisée vous qui te connaissais bien
ça avec le luxe est ce que vous pensez
que ta culture française elle peut
résister à
justement à cette dilution
dans des groupes qui pourrait rivaliser
avec les grands groupes mondiaux ou au
contraire est-ce qu'on va y perdre c'est
ce qu'il faudrait faire pour qu'on
puisse garder c'est à dire est-ce que
simplement ça doit passer par du mécénat
pour continuer à faire vivre
notre culture et nos particularités
françaises et européennes bien
la culture française est évident qu'il
faut les médias français participe à son
développement et d'ailleurs je crois que
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
au canal + par exemple finances
énormément de films français et que
toute cette activité là contribuent au
développement de la culture française
maintenant
c'est aussi difficile de faire face au
succès énorme des films américains que
partout et on peut pas les interdire on
peut pas faire comme certains pays qui
imite un production alors d'autres
créations
dont il ya également une question de
concurrence
des créations jeu dans nos métiers c'est
la même chose mais on promeut
mondialement des marques françaises qui
ont
un appel extraordinaire sur la clientèle
internationale aux états unis en chine
au japon en mai
quelquefois
était sont créées par des créateurs qui
travaillent avec nous et qui sont pas
forcément français la créatrice de
christian dur actuellement et une
italienne
donc mais elle défend de manière
formidable la marque christian dior et
arrive à lui faire atteindre un degré de
désirabilité dans le monde
exceptionnel donc et on avait
une dizaine d'années un autre créateur
chez dior qui était aussi non français
et un anglais donc il se plaît john
galliano qui lui aussi avait apporté un
souffle créatif formidable donc la
culture française elle est restée et
dior c'est une marque française dont il
faut c'est arrivé arriver à faire ça
maintenant au niveau de
la culture
pur littéraires ou cinématographiques
c'est probablement un peu plus difficile
nous l'allons est d'ailleurs en héros
qu'il faudra essayer de trouver
développer un peul usage de la langue
française qui devait être la langue
normalement utilisé la brussels et
maintenant tout se passe en anglais
alors que les anglais sont sortis
prendre à ce sujet
oui bonjour monsieur monsieur arnaud
plus d'abord une remarque préalable à
l'adresse de mes collègues parce que ça
s'est déjà dit hier quand on a reçu un
monsieur bolloré ya pas les français qui
aiment la réussite française et ceux qui
l'aiment bah moi je vous croise pas tous
les matins des français qui n'aime pas
la réussite française vous peut-être
qu'ils en attendent pour vous en croisez
beaucoup mais personnellement j'en
croise pas beaucoup de ce type là par
contre c'est vrai qu'en france yens
passion de l'égalité
et que quand des gens gagnent énormément
d'argent et que d'autres ont du mal à
vivre mais il ya une attention française
à cette question il ya des gens qui
peuvent aimer la réussite française est
pensé que ça se résume pas au cac 40 qui
peuvent aimer l'art citons 16 et on sait
que monsieur arnaud devrait payer
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune
c'est pas
tout ça n'est pas contradictoire
mais la question de la commission dans
quel nom mais puisque ça fait plusieurs
fois qu'on entend ces remarques et que
notre audition et retransmise c'est pas
inutile quand même de mettre les points
sur les i sur cette question
une remarque aussi préalable vous avez à
plusieurs reprises ça a été abordée
balayé d'un revers de main la question
de la condamnation enfin deux pas de la
condamnation de la convention judiciaire
que vous savez signé avec la justice
on peut quand même s'étonner puisque
vous avez l'air sûr de vous sur
l'innocence de votre groupe de payer
quand même 10 millions d'euros pour
éteindre une procédure judiciaire 10
millions d'euros c'est quand même
beaucoup d'argent on va évidemment on
n'a pas vous et moi exactement le même
rapport à ce que représente 10 millions
d'euros mais c'est quand même beaucoup
d'argent
donc si vous étiez si sûr de vous
pourquoi avoir accepté l'extension cette
procédure jeudi serbes ont encore un
sens s'en étonner
ensuite je voudrais revenir sur la
question
de la concentration le problème je suis
arnaud c'est que vous n'êtes pas seuls à
être propriétaires de gros pour nous et
finalement vous êtes très peu nombreux
aujourd'hui
vous monsieur bolloré à monsieur draghi
fut niel donc en fait quelques grandes
fortunes quand on vous fait le con tu
possèdes l'essentiel aujourd'hui du
paysage médiatique français et celle à
qui un sujet qui nous amène à à débattre
de la question de la concentration
donc en fait les règles dans ce monde là
à ce fonds avec une influence importante
de ces propriétaires là vous ne pouvez
pas dire par exemple que renvoyer comme
ça la question des aides à la presse
parce que quand quand on discute de
savoir s'il faut réformer les aides à la
presse les journaux vous possédez
donnent leur avis sur cette question et
si tous les journaux possédé par ses
gros de le même avis c'est à dire il
faut pas réformer les aides à la presse
elles ne sont pas réformées aujourd'hui
elles sont profondément inégalitaire et
on pourrait effectivement imaginer
l'autre et d'ailleurs il ya d'autres qui
ont existé par exemple on a créé à une
époque une aide au quotidien faibles
ressources publicitaires
elle est aujourd'hui très faible
alors qu'on sait que la publicité est
une arme économies très importantes pour
l'existence ou la non existence des
journaux donc oui vous avez un avis sur
ces questions là vous avez un avis à
travers les titres que vous possédez
aujourd'hui vous avez d' influence à
travers les titres que vous possédez sur
la question des aides à la presse sur la
question de m faut-il ou non renforcé
les lois anti concentration
faut-il ou non réformé la répartition de
la publicité qui fait vivre ou fait
mourir des titres de presse aujourd'hui
donc vous êtes un acteur de cette
question vous ne pouvez pas je veux dire
parce que vous voit défiler les harpes
réseau de petites mais moi je suis un
tout petit acteur de sa poche et bolloré
nous a dit
tout vraiment tout petit petit vous êtes
tous tout petit mais le problème c'est
qu'au total vous êtes 4 ou 5 à tous
possédés donc vous pouvez pas dire que
les décisions qui sont prises dans ce
secteur vous n'y êtes pour rien donc
effectivement nous pensons enfin nous
sommes un certain nombre à penser qu' il
faudrait sûrement se pencher sur les
règles actuelles parce que nous voyons
le paysage se rétrécir le paysage
démocratique se rétrécir et ça n'est pas
le fait de mettre en cause les titres
que vous possédez mais au total le
paysage se rétrécit le nombre de titres
se rétrécit les questions de pluralisme
sont sans cesse posé et part de très
loin la confiance net-citoyens s'érode
donc il faut changer des règles et vous
pouvez pas juste nous dire faites
confiance à quelques grands champions
qui vont résoudre tous les problèmes
effectivement les problèmes le mécénat
comme vous avez dit ne suffira pas à
faire vivre durablement le pluralisme de
la presse voilà ce qui nous préoccupe
ici
si vous voulez voyager ou pas
non monsieur laurent a posé plusieurs
questions
[Musique]
très brièvement
sur il dit vous avez beaucoup d'argent
le fortuné ces terrains et le com de
signaler et vous faire remarquer que
l'essentiel de ce qui est recouvert par
ce terme ce sont les actions du groupe
lvmh et comme ce groupe grâce à tous ses
employés ses 175 1000 employés dont plus
de 40 mille en france dont plus de 5000
10000 recruter tous les ans avec 100
sites industriels c'est que vous êtes
attentifs à ça 100 sites de manufacture
artisanale en france 500
sous traitants bon grâce à la réussite
de toutes ces équipes qui est travail de
quarante ans
ces actions beaucoup monté
mais c'est pas sur mon compte en banque
je sais d action qui servent à l'outil
industriel donc il faut pas confondre
les celui qui a gagné au loto et qui
peut elle est dépensé et un industriel
comme moi qui a des actions bon qui va
le faire c'est vrai le total boscher
mais elles sont là elles sont
inamovibles je ne peux pas les utiliser
pour mes dépenses personnelles g elles
sont parties de l'actif industrielle de
la france est probablement une belle
entreprise de notre pays et qui
d'ailleurs fait la fierté de ses
employés vous qui êtes
attachés aux ouvriers terrain vous savez
très bien que
une employée qui rentre chez vuitton
pour elle c'est formidable elle a un
salaire supérieur à ceux qui sont payés
dans son environnement
un travail tout à fait intéressant et
c'est vraiment extrêmement valorisant et
d'ailleurs
construit des ateliers régulièrement aux
lardons oui vous dire quand vous savez
ce ce terme de richesse oui d'accord ça
vaut de l'argent mais c'est un outil
industriel c'est pas de l'argent sur un
compte en banque alors les dix millions
qu'on a payé d'abord je vais rappeler
tout à l'heure
ça c'est une demande qui nous a été
faite par la justice
pourquoi on accepter
nous avons été
dans le papier qui a été signée
reconnu non coupable
mais si on ne faisait pas ça
on était embarqué dans un procès par
ricochet rufin tous ces gens là ce sera
un levier à nous mettre dans ce procès
qu'on aurait probablement lancerait
sortie est attendue
il n'y aura pas de jugement vous avez
éteint la procédure aux jeux
laissez-moi vous laisser finir les
chroniques et de la logique
ce procès aurait duré plusieurs années
pendant plusieurs années le nom du
groupe aurait été mêlé à une histoire se
passe exactement lesquels
alors qu'ils kiki à lui continue de
procédure et on a effectivement préféré
éviter ça éviter d'avoir le nom du
groupe traîner dans la procédure
judiciaire pendant plusieurs années
alors qu'on n'était rien à se reprocher
et on a accepté à la demande du juge de
payer cette somme voilà qui est dit est
ce qu'il est qui à l'échelle du groupe
étaient abordables et c'est tout c'est
pour éviter de quelque sorte abîmé un
petit peu l'image du groupe dans un
procès bon alors après sur la
concentration tout ça c'est vrai que
on peut on peut en discuter
en centration
moi je pense que les actionnaires
aujourd'hui ils sont très utiles à
l'avenir
de des médias dont ils sont
propriétaires en particulier nos médias
qu'est ce qu'on essaye de faire je pense
que père louette a dit houle expiré
qu'on voulait positionner on essaye de
les transformer dans le monde numérique
pour justement arrivé à concurrencer
ceux cette concurrence énorme des des
médias américains et pour faire ça ça
nécessite beaucoup de moyens
et on arrive petit à petit on quand on
est arrivé au au quotidien
au parisien
est quasiment pas d'abonné numérique
aujourd'hui on a près de quarante mille
abonnés et ça augmente très vite
c'est ça qu'il faut développer mais ça
vous fait danser et et les abonnés
numériques vous savez ça raconte banques
chinoises
les plaçant capo-canellas ce merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur
arnaud de votre d'autres éclairages faut
d'abord rappeler que l'objet de la
commission dans lequel j'ai sous les
yeux c'est de mettre en lumière les
processus ayant permis ou pouvant
aboutir à une concentration dans les
médias
en france et d'évaluer l'impact de cette
concentration sur la démocratie je le
dis parce que on a abordé de 6 $ ce
nombre de questions de procédure il
semble qu'ils sont closes et qui me
semble un peu étrange et à l'objet qui
est celui de votre présence
je rappeler qu' on est nombreux à être
conscients que nous avons besoin
d'investisseurs et que nous aurons
besoin de capitaine d'industrie et bravo
au groupe fait rayonner la france quoi
alors ceci posé dans les médias
particulièrement il ya le sujet est issu
de la commission en caisse et la
concentration dont on nous dit depuis
lundi puisqu'on a eu un professeur
d'université on a eu un de vos collègues
investisseurs on comprend que la
concentration est effectivement un sujet
qui peut avoir une utilité notamment
pour résister face aux géants d'internet
et pour promouvoir les valeurs
démocratiques française à l'étranger
bois alors comment on règle ça parce que
en france on a un peu peur de la
concentration et comme on nous dit
effectivement si vous regardez on n'est
pas très gros
mais est ce qu'il ya une amélioration à
conduire pour faire que c'est requis et
de la concentration mais que sur la
question de des rédactions
l'indépendance et cetera est-ce qu'on
peut pas apporter une pierre qui donne
une garantie c'est ça c'est un peu la
première question est deuxième question
tout à l'heure vous avez un peu esquissé
sujet comment vous voyez la capacité
collective de la france a résisté face
au géant d'internet qu'est-ce-qu'il
qu'est ce qui nous manque
gardot
sur la première partie est donc
comment comment faire
difficile moi je ne suis pas législateur
j'ai déjà du mal à ce que je pense mais
c'est que
chaque journal chaque média quand même
une ligne
[Musique]
cette ligne
il faut quelques pas par exemple
les échos les échos c'est un journal
économique qui est
un défenseur ou un illustrateur de
l'économie de marché bon et en tant
qu'actionnaire c'est une ligne laquelle
on a adhéré après ce sont les actions
qui la met en
le parisien c'est un journal
terré
populaire
plutôt
général
qui est globalement
un journal de nature à seissan test mais
assez oecuméniques dans lequel les
électeurs
s'intéressent essentiellement pourquoi
même le savoir aux sports et aux faits
divers d'ailleurs leur parti fédéral
très bien sait pas si vous avez lu
récemment les articles sur les
différents assassinats les touts les
propres procédures
c'est très très bien fait bon ok donc ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que quand
tant qu'actionnaire
moi ça me va très bien après le journal
est responsable parce que ce que ce
qu'il faut éviter mc qu'il se mette dans
une situation où l'actionnaire se
trouvent
parce que c'est pas les nouvelles
réglementations éventuelles sont en trop
et
compliqué ou
trop stricte
se mettre à la situation où la ligne
change
par exemple si demain
on se trouvait avec un parisien qui
devient un journal
sur un extrême ou sur un autre
il faut que les actionnaires puissent
réagir en
bas je n'ai pas envie d'avoir un journal
qui deviennent
financer un journal qui le deviennent
le support d extrême droite ou d'extrême
gauche mais s'il ya une indépendance
absolue totale on sait jamais donc il
faut quand même qu'on puisse réagir au
moment où renault le même si je prends
un exemple stupide mais si le pas si les
échos demain devait défendre l'économie
marxiste qui me plaît peut-être le seul
on sait rien
quand même c'est quand même extrêmement
gênant
bon
concept et des garde-fous j'ai des potes
qu'il faut rien changer mais je pense
qu'ils occupent qualité des garde-côtes
et des garde-fous par d'oran excusez moi
oui je suis d entendre vous avez entendu
tissus légers pcc se masquer un c'était
bon c'est pas moi là et alors que la
deuxième question était sur le
comment faire tous
les géants d'internet pour l'instant je
pense que la seule façon de résister
c'est justement de renforcer ceux qui
peuvent le faire c'est à dire de
d'augmenter et la présence internet de
tous ces médias et que les français
investissent dans les start up
en espérant que la prochaine la
prochaine vague en niçois ont dit soit
vraiment associer parce qu'on a raté la
précédente la liane à une nouvelle avec
le métavers lnf t il à vous avez suivi
ça bien sûr bon essayons d'être à temps
dans votre intervention à l'instant où
j'ai fait une référence à un actionnaire
qui se trouverait dans une situation où
la ligne éditoriale d'un média
changerait je ne sais pas si vous
faisiez référence à à un
média en particulier j'ai bien compris
que c'était pas les ce que vous
contrôlez mais cette remarque est
parfois faite sur ces news à propos de
ces news le fait qu'ils aient eu un
changement de ligne éditoriale avec un
une orientation
politique plus marqué à vous n'êtes pas
de commenter l'orientation de ces news
mais est-ce que si ce cas de figure se
se révéler c'est à dire que quelqu'un
qui utilise en fait à ma diable pour
faire passer d'aidé des lignes
politiques extrêmes est-ce que vous
comprendriez que le régulateur
interviennent de manière plus marquée
qui ne le fait jusqu'à présent
je pense qu'il faut faire tout ça avec
une grande prudence parce que ça peut
aller dans un sens ou dans un autre et
se révéler aussi contreproductif il faut
faire attention aux moi je vous donner
un exemple
théorique de ce qui pourrait
arrivées et dans le sens il faut quand
même que les actionnaires puissent
réagir et l'actionnaire ne soit pas mis
pour un voilier avec
une rédaction qui d'un seul coup font
des raisons diverses mais complètement
diverger et sans pouvoir rien dire ces
voiliers c'est c'est quand même si si
demain je vais pas faire ça mais je
finance et moi un journal the lancet moi
même un journal en étant à la tête du
journal bon là c'est autre chose je
ferai les choses mais là
la direction est complètement
données de manière indépendante à une
équipe c'est le cas actuellement
pierre louette il gère tout ça
voit rarement il y avait de vous le dire
vraiment
dernière question de du rapporteur
oui bon beaucoup de choses ont été dites
et changer sur le fond c'est aussi
l'occasion d'avoir des échanges a avec
des industriels sur sur l'économie d'un
secteur donc
le débat franchement je n'ai pas de
considérer que parce que l'on pose des
questions
qu'on exerce un droit aussi de critiques
cela veut dire que l'on essaye de
dévaloriser ou de critiquer de façon
systémique on va dire une réussite
française
je suis très très fier quand
des sociétés d innovation des créations
des sportives des artistes français
rayonne dans le monde et quand je me
promène dans le monde je suis très
heureux qu'on dit du bien de telle ou
telle chose que l'on fait et plutôt
qu'un verse
et d'ailleurs faut arrêter aussi la
petite musique que y a qu'en france
qu'on critique comme ça ailleurs ils
sont très fiers d'eux il ya des gens qui
critiquent aux états unis leurs fleurons
toute la journée c'est le propre des
démocraties et les seuls endroits où on
critique pas d'ailleurs les puissants du
pays on va dire qu'ils soient
économiques ou politiques se sont dans
dans les dictatures ou dans les régimes
très autoritaire donc voilà y'a pas de
dans tous les cas nous ici on est plutôt
dans une réflexion
sur
ouverte sur comment réussir à faire
qu'il puisse y avoir
un secteur de l'audiovisuel de la presse
même de la création puisque audiovisuel
touche pas seulement à l'information
qu'ils puissent être puissant dans un
monde très dur de concurrence notamment
avec le numérique qui est arrivé les
plates formes tout en gardant justement
ce qui est une force et une fierté
française un système démocratique
d'une presse très diverses d'un
audiovisuel avec une régulation qui
justement faisait que la leur en laisse
est de faire vivre dans la coup ce qui
est nos principes constitutionnels
liberté l'indépendance et le pluralisme
des médias donc c'est vraiment là-dessus
contrat et c'est comment concilier et
faire en sorte que dans un univers où la
tendance est à la concentration parce
que il ya les géants du net eh bien on
n'écrase pas cette diversité ce
pluralisme qui ne passe par du
foisonnement par des petites entités
aussi qu'ils peuvent pour qui doit
pouvoir vivre par des niches et c est
pas par des monopoles qui était l'ancien
système de leurs terres
donc voilà
cette mise au point
ensuite une
deuxième remarque est une question
je suis très étonné de ce que vous nous
avez répondu à monsieur k long et à moi
même je
vois là on laissera juge désormais quand
même
une commission denquête cette importance
que ce que l'on peut y dire je lis le
compte rendu du monde alors peut être
qu'il y avait eu un démenti de votre
part je comprendrais mais qui dit cette
enquête a notamment mis en milieu en
lumière la surveillance etc et puis dit
textuellement le groupe de bernard non
reconnaît ainsi les faits et accepte de
rézé autres et de réguler au trésor
public une amende de 10 millions d'euros
contre l'extinction de l'action bon vous
avez dit absolument l'averse pour vous
maintenez cette inverse
micro monsieur arnaud parce que sinon on
ne va pas vous entendre voilà oui
oui c'est la deuxième erreur de ce
journal que l'on a noté aujourd'hui
c'est faux on absolument pas reconnu une
culpabilité dans cette chose à belize et
le document vieux jeu
je n'ai pas dit culpabilité et moi je ne
dirai pas ce que j'ai pas enquêter c'est
le journal qui dit le reconnaît ainsi
les faits
vous connais ainsi l'effet est
d'ailleurs ensuite tout le reste y
compris de déclaration de vos
représentants à l'audience vont dans ce
sens de dire que y compris le ménage a
été fait dans la maison ce sont des
faits anciens et c'est pour cela que
c'est bien ça c'est bien ça le dit il
n'y a aucune culpabilité
de du groupe lvmh et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a signé ce document à
la demande de la justice
ensuite alors la dame a question elle
est la suivante qui est pour une
précision parce que je les pose est de
façon peut-être un peu vous avez dit en
gros que vous êtes rentré dans le
secteur de la presse à des moments où
des titres étaient en difficulté ou vous
le demander
je pense qu'au printemps dernier
ou c'est vous qui avez fait une promesse
de rachat
e
une proposition pardon de rachat
pour le jdd et pour paris match vous me
confirmez scott pye on y dans la presse
donc on a l'occasion de vous poser les
questions directement
alors qu'il y avait une négociation avec
monsieur bolloré la même équipe mais
équipes ont probablement
examiner différentes choses mais on n'a
jamais fait propositions n'ont
même précisément dit que vous avez fait
une proposition d'un de 80 millions
donc ça vous ne confirmait pas non
très bien une question
qu'est-ce que merci messieurs arnaud
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et de
nous avoir donné votre vision de ce
paysage des médias
vous avez suivi l'audition de bernard
arnault le pdg du groupe lvmh qui
détient le parisien aujourd'hui en
france les échos radio classique il
était entendu dans le cadre de la
commission qui enquête sur la
concentration des médias et qui est
chargé d'étudier si cette concentration
a un impact sur notre démo démocratie
bernard arnault a plusieurs fois répété
au cours de cette audition qu'il n'était
pas spécialiste des médias mais que la
liberté de la presse était toujours
respecté dans son groupe et que le pôle
média était totalement indépendant il a
aussi appelé à la défense des médias
français face aux géants du numérique
d'autres auditions suivront dans les
prochains jours celles de patrick drahi
le patron d'altis qui détient bfm tv et
rmc celle d'arnaud lagardère qui détient
paris match et europe 1 et enfin celle
de martin bouygues dont le groupe tf1
envisage une fusion avec m6 ce qui en
ferait le plus gros mastodontes de
l'audiovisuel français les détails de
ces auditions sont à retrouver à chaque
fois sur notre site publicsenat.fr les
auditions elles sont à revivre sur tous
nos réseaux sociaux l'actualité